one of the most valuable skills to have
as a full stack web developer is without
a doubt no js and that's not going to
change anytime soon but you might be
wondering why i'm making a node tutorial
in 2020 because if you've been watching
the news you may have heard that node
was killed last week by deno when i lay
my vengeance upon making the extremely
chaotic javascript world even more
convoluted if you're just starting to
learn javascript this can be very
confusing and you might be wondering
should i learn node or deno the answer
is node especially if you want to get a
job or build a product when something
becomes as established as node it
doesn't get replaced you'll see things
like this happen all the time a few
years ago everybody was saying graphql
would replace rest and 10 years ago
people were saying no js would replace
php these predictions never pan out and
are just built on top of hype that being
said i do think denno is awesome and has
a bright future
both both
both is good and if you learn node today
those skills will mostly transfer to
deno tomorrow in today's video you'll
learn the basics of node.js in seven
easy steps then we'll put those steps
together to build a full stack web
application because in my opinion the
best way to learn how to code is to
build something meaningful from scratch
by the end of the video we'll deploy our
code to the cloud so you can show off
your api to your friends and family if
you're new here like and subscribe and
head over to fireship io to follow along
with the full write-up to this video
step one is to understand what node.js
is and why you would want to use it
node.js itself is not a programming
language but rather a runtime that
allows you to run javascript on a server
you see when javascript first came
around in the 1990s it was designed as a
simple scripting language to run in the
browser as the web platform evolved
javascript became more and more powerful
and in 2009 we saw the initial release
of node.js now up until this time it was
impossible to write javascript code on
the server most servers were written in
languages like java or php it
revolutionized web development because
now a web developer could write a full
stack application in a single language
so that's all node.js is it's a way for
developers to write javascript on the
server when it could previously only be
written in a web browser now there are a
lot of low-level implementation details
here that you don't need to know about
as a beginner but if you really want to
dive into how node.js works check out my
how it's made video but what kind of
problems can node.js actually solve
nodejs can do a lot so instead of
listing out a bunch of use cases i'll
show you how to build a full stack web
application from scratch this is how
it'll work you visit a url on the
internet that points to your server when
the request is received we can use node
to handle the request and read a file
from the server's file system
and then respond back to the client so
they can view the html in the browser
step 2 how to install nodejs node can be
installed on windows mac or linux and is
probably already installed on your
system in this tutorial i'll be using
ubuntu via the windows subsystem for
linux at this point i've just opened up
an empty directory in vs code and then
pulled up a terminal session you can
find out if node is installed on your
system by running node flag v from the
command line as you can see here i'm
running version 12.16 which is the
current long-term support version if you
get an error at this point it means that
you don't have node installed and even
if you do have node installed it'd be a
very good idea to use a package called
node version manager to manage the
installation of different node versions
on your system there's an nvm package
for mac and linux or a separate package
for windows go ahead and follow the
instructions to install nvm on your
system and that will give you the
ability to install any version of
node.js that you want for example you
could run nvm install 12.16.3
then run nvm use to use that specific
version as your runtime and now that we
have node.js installed we can move on to
step three hello world but first if
you're serious about nodejs consider
becoming a pro member at fireship io
it'll give you access to my full length
courses almost all of which cover
advanced use cases for node.js but we
need to walk before we can run so how do
we actually use this thing one way to
mess around with node is in repel mode
which stands for read of owl print loop
when you type node into the command line
it allows you to run javascript code and
we'll print out the results for example
we can type console.log hello world and
it will log that value out this is nice
for messing around but go ahead and hit
ctrl c twice to shut it down because in
most cases we'll want to execute
javascript code that lives in an actual
file the default entry point into a
node.js app is the index.js file go
ahead and create an index.js file
manually in vs code then inside that
file add console.log hello world you can
now run the code inside this file with
the node command followed by the path to
this file and because it's an index file
you can actually just point to the
parent directory congratulations you
just built a node app
step four understand the node runtime in
most ways javascript works the same way
it does in the browser as it does in ojs
but there are some very important
differences you should know about first
node has a handful of built-in
identifiers one of those globals is
console which we've already been using
to log out values to the terminal
there's another global with a name of
global this object is a namespace that
is available throughout the entire node
process for example if we assigned a
lucky number property to global we could
then access it anywhere else in our code
if you're a frontend web developer you
can compare global to the window object
in the browser now i think the most
important global to be familiar with is
process which gives you access to the
currently running node process you might
use it to check the current platform or
operating system which in my case is
linux or grab an environment variable
from your server
but this gives us a great opportunity to
segue into step five how do events work
in node.js you'll often hear people
describe it as an asynchronous
event-driven javascript runtime the
runtime implements a thing called an
event loop just like a web browser does
and it allows node to push intensive
operations off to a separate thread so
only very fast non-blocking operations
happen on the main thread and this is
why people often call node non-blocking
it's a design choice that makes node.js
very suitable for things that require
high throughput like real-time
applications web servers and things like
that okay so how does that affect me as
a coder well normally you won't have to
think about the low-level details you
just need to know how events and
callbacks work in most cases you'll
listen to events events can come in many
forms but one example is on the process
global that we looked at earlier before
a node process finishes it emits an
event named exit we can listen to this
event using on and then register a
callback function as the second argument
when the exit event occurs nodejs will
run this function and that's where it
gets the name callback because the
function isn't called the first time
node.js sees it it's only called after
the exit event occurs at some point in
the future this event is built into node
but you can also create your own from
scratch we'll import an event emitter
from the events module that is built
into node and we'll look at modules in
more detail in just a minute we can
create a custom event emitter by
instantiating the class and then we'll
register a callback that fires on the
lunch event now that the callback is
registered you can simply call event
emitter emit with that event name
and that triggers your callback function
to run as you can see here we emit the
event twice which will run the callback
function twice
this event driven style of programming
is extremely useful when you have
something that is cpu intensive and with
that we can move on to step 6 the file
system node has a built-in file system
module called fs it can read write and
delete files on the file system among
other things and it can also do things
in a blocking or non-blocking way allow
me to explain that by showing you an
example first create a file on the file
system called hello.txt and then add
whatever text you want inside of it in
our javascript code we'll import two
functions from the file system module
called read file and read file sync
anytime you see a function that ends in
sync think blocking or in other words it
will need to finish all of its work
before any of your other code can run we
can read a text file in node by simply
passing the path to that file and then
we'll specify the encoding as utf-8
now reading a file might take a while
especially if it's a very large file and
what you'll notice here when we run our
code is that the second console log
won't run until after that file has been
read luckily you can make your code
non-blocking by refactoring this to a
callback with readfile we pass the same
first two arguments and then add a
callback function as the third argument
inside the function we can access an
error object if the operation fails or
when successful the actual text from the
file the super cool thing about this is
that even though the console log to the
text file comes first in our script it's
not the thing that gets executed first
node registers the callback executes the
rest of the script and then finally runs
the callback when the file has been read
so that gives us two different ways to
read a file but there's actually one
other way we could go about this and
that's using a promise based solution
promises are also asynchronous and
non-blocking and they tend to produce
much cleaner code when compared to
callbacks notice how in this example
we're importing readfile from the
promises namespace this gives us a
function that returns a promise when
called if you're using the latest
bleeding edge version of node you could
potentially use this function with top
level weight which means you can use a
weight to resolve the promise here at
the top of the script however since
we're currently using node version 12
we'll go ahead and wrap this in an async
function and this async await syntax
will make your code much easier to read
especially when you have multiple async
calls in the same function
okay so now that you know how to read
files i want to backtrack a little bit
and talk about this require function
that you've seen me use in the past
couple examples step 7 modules a module
is nothing more than a javascript file
that exports its code node has a bunch
of built-in modules like fs and events
that we've already looked at and there's
a long list of other modules beyond that
the traditional way to import a module
in node is to use this require function
but a quick side note on that first
because node recently added support for
es modules which used the import export
syntax most node.js code out there
written in vanilla javascript still uses
require so it's very important for you
to know as a node.js developer and if
all that's confusing to you well all i
can say is welcome to the javascript
world let's look at how we can use
modules in our own codebase create a new
file to serve as your module then go
into your index.js file create a
variable for the module and then import
it using require when you console log it
you'll notice that it's currently just
an empty object in order to make a
module useful you need to export some
code from it in the modules file you can
reference this object with
module.exports
you can add new properties to the object
or redefine it as a new object in either
case whatever you add here will now be
available to use in the other file and
as you can see the object is no longer
empty when we console.log it but at some
point you'll very likely want to use
somebody else's code out there in the
world and the primary place to do that
is via node package manager or npm which
was recently acquired by github which
itself was recently acquired by
microsoft when you installed node
earlier in the video it also installed
npm
which is a tool you can use to install
remote packages to use in your own code
the first step we'll want to take is to
open the command line and run npm in net
we'll use the y flag to use the default
options and what you'll notice is that
it creates a package json file here in
the root of the application this file
can contain metadata about your project
but most importantly it keeps track of
the dependencies that you use here at
this point we haven't installed anything
yet so let's go ahead and change that by
opening the command line again and
running npm install express express is a
minimal web application framework and
one of the most popular third-party node
modules after running the command you'll
notice a few things happened here in the
package.json file it added express to
the dependencies and pegged it to a
specific version this dependencies
object allows you to manage multiple
dependencies in a project and then
reinstall them all at once on a
different system now the actual raw
source code for the dependency lives in
this node modules directory you should
never have to modify code in the node
modules directory if you find yourself
writing code in here you're probably
doing it wrong that's because the
package json controls how this directory
is built it fetches your remote packages
saves the source code here and that
process should be able to be repeated on
any system now that we have this package
installed we can import it by name in
our javascript code in this case we
simply require express and now we've
reached the point where we're ready to
put these seven steps together to build
a real full stack application and deploy
it to the cloud what we're building here
is actually just your typical full stack
web application our server will live on
a url and when a user makes a request to
this url in the browser the server will
respond with some html in our code we'll
first create an instance of an express
app an express app allows us to create
different urls and endpoints that a user
can navigate to in the browser and then
we define code for the server to handle
those requests now i don't want to get
too deep into http but when the user
navigates to a url in the browser it's
what's known as a get request which
means they're requesting some data on
the server and not trying to modify or
update anything on the server with
express we can set up an endpoint like
that by calling app.get and then the
first argument is the url that the user
will navigate to in this case we'll just
use a forward slash for the root url but
feel free to create multiple pages for
your web app by creating different urls
the second argument here is our callback
function you can think of every request
to this url as an event and then you
handle that event with this function and
express gives us two parameters to make
use of the request and the response the
request is the incoming data from the
user in this example we don't really
need to parse any data from the request
however in many cases you might want to
look at the headers or the body of the
request to authenticate a user or
understand what the user is trying to do
at this point we need to implement the
code to handle the request what we want
to do is read some html from our file
system and then send it back down to the
browser as you can see here i'm creating
a file called home.html with just some
generic html markup inside
in our source code we can then import
read file from node's file system module
just like we did earlier we'll read the
file use utf-8 encoding
then in our callback function here we'll
have access to the html string and we
can send a response back down to the
client by calling response.send and also
if there's an error in the callback we
can handle that by sending a response
with a status code of 500 which means a
server error
so the user knows that something went
wrong on the server and that's all there
is to it we now have a way to send html
from the server to the client now we
just need to tell our express app to
start listening to incoming requests we
do that by defining a port which will
normally come from a node environment
variable then we call app.listen with
that port and when it starts up we'll
console.log that the app is available on
localhost 3000. you can start it up by
opening the command line and running
node with the current working directory
if you go ahead and open it in the
browser you should see your html
returned back to you
now there is one important thing you
should know at this point and that's
that callbacks can be very difficult to
work with especially as your app grows
in complexity it often leads to a state
known as callback hell where you have a
bunch of callbacks nested within
callbacks within more callbacks and so
on
a great way to avoid code like this is
to use promises instead of callbacks and
that's very easy to do in node.js
instead of importing read file from fs
we'll import it from fs.promises we can
make our callback function async and
then we can write the response in a
single line of code by saying response
send and then await the operation to
read file that's much more concise and
readable but it's especially useful when
you have multiple async operations to
handle in a single request
so now that we've built a node.js app
how do we deploy it to the cloud so
people can actually use it there's a
bunch of different ways we could do it
but an easy and free way is with google
app engine app engine has what's known
as a standard environment for node.js up
to version 12. and what that does is
provide you with a server in the cloud
that scales automatically based on the
incoming traffic to your app it's
incredibly easy to set up but you first
need to have a google cloud platform
account and also the google cloud
command line tools installed on your
local system once you have that done you
can simply go into your source code and
create an app.yaml file this file is
used to configure your cloud server the
only thing we need at this point is to
specify a runtime of node.js version 12.
app engine will run your code by looking
in the package.json file for a start
script so let's go in there and define a
start script that runs node in the
current working directory to start our
express app from there we can simply
open the command line and run gcloud app
deploy that'll take a minute and then it
will give you a url where you can access
your app publicly on the web
congratulations you're now a full stack
cloud architect
if this video helped you please like and
subscribe and if you really want to dive
deep into nodejs and express consider
becoming a pro member at fireship io i
have a whole bunch of advanced content
covering real world use cases with these
technologies thanks for watching and i
will see you in the next one
[Music]